[Music]
there's a long tradition in hollywood of
remaking old tv shows but recently a new
trend has emerged of taking old movies
and tv shows that are fun and light and
turning them dark and gritty sabrina the
teenage witch the original batman and
fresh prince of bel-air have all
rebooted recently with a darker edge and
they've been pretty successful it turns
out people like a little edginess to
their shows and we want to say we hear
you and that is why we're launching a
new gritty remake of the amber ruffin
show the trailer for it just dropped
check it out
coming to you from 30 rockefeller plaza
in new york city it's
a gritty take
on a late-night show
look at them tarek
going about their lives as if
everything's going to be okay
city is a cesspool it's
amber ruffin they'll need to learn the
truth it's been a crazy week in america
we're gonna find out what happened see
amber like you've never seen her before
slightly less
happy
and that was the monologue did you like
the monologue
trick question
i don't care
amber we have a problem corrine is
pitching the coca-cola sketch again
she's threatening to go to the press if
we don't do it i'll handle her
you just handled my alibi where did that
come from
yo mama the amber ruffin show starring
ambrose
corinne
and amber's cue card guy
wally
way do they get a load of me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you